d'anciennes prothèse reconverti en
oeuvre d'art si michel a pour habitude
de réaliser ses sculptures pour le
plaisir cette fois ci il le fait à
contribution de l'hôpital c'est un peu
comme une boucle ce petit clin d'oeil
qui part justement de l'est fait que les
pièces sont recyclés et que l'argent de
le bénéfice de cette vente reviendra
automatiquement fonds de dotation un
fonds de dotation pour le centre
hospitalier de versailles l'hôpital
lance un appel au mécénat pour soutenir
l'établissement conférences concerts et
vente aux enchères vont ponctuer ce
week-end de lancement pour récolter des
fonds
l'objectif de réduction des déficits des
comptes publics a amené le gouvernement
à demander aux établissements de santé
réduire leurs charges et cette réduction
de charges elle s'est traduite pour le
moment par une diminution des tarifs
pour les hôpitaux une diminution
tarifaire qui représente une perte de 2
millions d'euros sur l'année 2015 pour
le fonds de dotation trois objectifs ont
été fixés
l'amélioration de conditions de vie des
patients le développement de la
recherche et la modernisation des
équipements
ça va aussi bien d'une gamma caméra en
médecine nucléaire ou d'une irm dont qui
sont de très gros équipements qui valent
plusieurs millions d'euros avec
l'ouverture de nouveaux services comme
celui de la médecine nucléaire inauguré
il ya trois mois mais aussi une forte
augmentation du recours aux services des
urgences
la direction de l'hôpital s'est fixé
l'objectif de 200 mille euros de levée
de fonds annuelle des dons défiscalisés
hauteur de 60% pour les entreprises et
66 % pour les particuliers